while returning to our breaking news now
from South Africa where police have
arrested the Most Wanted fugitive in the
1994 Rwandan Genocide after decades on
the run his name fulgence kaishima he's
been a fugitive for more than 20 years
he's accused of organizing the killing
of nearly 2 000 Tutsis seeking shelter
at a Catholic Church
is an attorney and political analyst
he's with us live from their wand in
capital Kigali
shed some light put some context around
who this person is
is an important
person in in in in the in perpetrating
the genocide against the Tutsi because
what he did he first of all he starts
the killing a very early on the 6th of
April and as soon as uh you know as soon
as the genocide starts and now the the
thing is he breaks the past taboo
because while killing tooth is started
around 1959
they'd never been killed when they fled
into a church so what kaishema did by
you know by bringing Fuel and kidding
people in a church he breaks the past
taboo that was unheard of of killing
people who are so shelter in a church
and therefore the subsequent killings
Will Follow That pattern which is why
some of the tootsie who died they died
because they what they are sought
shelter in a church thinking that
Killers is not there
Crossing that barrier and going into a
church to kill people but as early as
the 6th of April Kai Shema kill people
in the church and then opens the door to
to people profaning even the church and
not fearing to pursue as truth is in
churches so that's an important uh
aspect uh of this situation but avoided
capture for a very long time how and
then when the sorry how how did he
manage to be a fugitive for more than
two decades being one of the most the
most Wanted fugitive left
because they it was because they have
networks so remember there are two
things and that's why this is very
important today there are networks of
people who support them first of all
that when when the French operation of
course comes to Rwanda they create some
sort of a buffer between the advancing
RPF and the fleeing uh genocide
perpetrators and the French allows them
to swim to DRC and ultimately explicit
them into Europe and in Europe they form
all sorts of networks where they protect
each other and some governments protect
them so for example the French
government has never expedited any
single genocide fugitive to Rwanda
because they you know because they're
these networks that protect them so
their networks in in Europe but there
are also networks in the neighboring
country in these artists intervened at a
very crucial moment in in time where uh
calls to kill Tutsi especially Eastern
India as we are on the rise again and
genocide denial is also on the rise so
this arrest is quite important and it's
sending a signal to people including
Congolese populists and politicians who
are calling for killings of tulipsy to
understand that they are they in court
is also going to come sooner or later so
I think this is an important development
at this time
where can you can you describe the
investigative work over such a long
period of time that goes into a capture
an arrest like the one we're seeing
today
right so Rwanda has the genocide
fugitive tracking units that works with
uh police and Justice institutions
across the world but while you send
indictments and in this case question
mark was understatement the
international criminal court
and and and which then when it closed
this doors submitted these indictments
and his filed to the London uh
prosecution while the Roman prosecution
can issue arrest warrants why
bounty to him it all depends
where this person is now unfortunately
governments of this world have sometimes
they don't have political will to to to
track and arrest these people so we are
very very pleased that South Africa has
finally uh done this because we know
some of the fugitives whereabouts are
known but the governments in those
countries are reluctant to to capture
them and and bring them to justice
thank you for joining us at such short
notice we just found out moments ago
about this information we'll speak to
you again thank you
thank you